[Music]
some of my critics will say that I focus
too much on the left and what I always
say is where I come from the left I'm
trying to cut my house everyone else is
a man right right amen right now you can
beam out of your own eye I tried for a
long time to tell progressives why they
were wrong it doesn't work right I know
MSNBC built a whole network to tell
conservatives how wrong they are
it doesn't work I'm pretty sure that is
not converted anyone I argue is probably
converted people to be stronger
conservatives in a lot of respects yeah
because they turn it on and they go wait
a minute this isn't true right or this
you know whatever but what else can we
hit the right on like I don't want it
not gotcha in a gotcha sense but what
else has the right sort of missed from a
lot you know I don't I I've made a
promise that I won't judge Donald Trump
on what he did during the election yeah
I'll judge him now on his actions as
president but there's a lot I disagree
with him on that he said during the
election a lot yeah if he passes a 1.1
billion stimulus package I might lose my
mind right this is not a conservative
idea to do you know in fact I remember
the tea party standing up and saying 780
I remember the number 787 billion dollar
stimulus package well I Got News for You
Donald Trump's will be bigger
yeah and will you accept it will you
accept government taking money and then
saying I know what's best to do with it
no there's that the the the to watch
people cheer the executive orders that
keep coming out that he's sitting there
signing decrees like Caesar I had a
problem with George W Bush doing it I
had a problem with Barack Obama I have a
problem with this guy and has anybody
noticed they're getting worse yeah
they're grabbing more power.we
have to restore the constitutional
balance of power yeah so that there's
video evidence of me saying the exact
same thing that I was against it
when George w did it I was against what
Obama did it I'm against it now and this
is the problem that if we removed one of
the three branches of government if we
just take the legislative branch out and
by the way it's plenty it's the fault of
the Senate too because they refused to
meet and do anything now that stuff but
that then we've seeded enough power to
the president where people don't even
understand cynics anymore right so so
he's assigning these things that
everyone goes oh I guess at how allows
me so the progressives started this by
taking away the true nature of the
Senate
remember the Senate was elected
originally the Senators were picked by
the states and the state legislators
yeah okay so they were picked by the
people who in their own state were
greedy for their own state right so they
would guard the state you would agree
you would argue that's a good thing
that's a great thing yeah great right
there okay so they were to guard the
state well the progressives took that
away so now we have a hundred men who
well I want to make sure that shows the
Schumer stays in or I want to make sure
Ted Cruz stays in well you shouldn't
have be connected unless you're in the
state of Texas or in the state of New
York so they change that basic
fundamental principle and then most
people don't know this do you know where
the Supreme Court used to meet before
FDR made this big edifice of the Supreme
Court with a big columns of the and
Moses up at the top do you know I'd
actually I didn't even know it met
anywhere else but I guess I would maybe
somewhere in Boston or that would after
that was built in the 1940s by Roosevelt
the Supreme Court played such a small
role that when they built the Capitol
they looked at each other when crap we
forgot about the third branch where did
is they met until the 1940s in the
basement of the Capitol okay there were
nothing they were just there to go yep
constitutional not constitutional but
again the progressives made them in to
this too now they're the final word well
they can't be dictators the president
can't be a dictator
and neither can Congress which is a
beautiful it's a beautiful system but
nobody else has it yeah or we're losing
it I know we are we are absolutely
losing it so okay so let's just talk
about one of the executive orders but
the one that everyone's going crazy
about the so-called Muslim ban now I did
a piece at the top of the show today
talking about that this is not a Muslim
ban because if you took the top five
most populous Muslim countries so that's
there which is almost 800 million people
they're not on there including Indonesia
and Pakistan and Saudi Arabia now you
could argue that certainly Saudi Arabia
should be on the list in Pakistan
probably - yeah okay for good reason
yeah for good for because there's
actually everybody that people have you
have right so okay but putting that
aside the rhetoric around it the
immediate need for the hashtag Muslim
ban oh my gosh Schumer crying talking
about a Muslim ban now we can we've
already agreed we don't like everything
being done via executive action but what
do you think about just the inability
for us to tell the truth in what's
happening that okay this may be
misguided but it is not about and yeah
this this gives me hope that America has
a chance sitting down with a guy who
used to say he was a progressive and
have you say that is so powerful so
powerful the problem is twofold first
thank you for being honest
thank you for having intellectual
courage to say that honey I know people
always say it seemed so rare or
something and it's like I'm not I didn't
pick a team I didn't pick you know to me
like I would say what I believed before
and I'm saying whatever we know I'm sure
I'll be wrong about things but right but
I'm a human but it will come with great
cost
it always does Reid I'll tell you after
the show we read a book called the
pendulum you'll understand what time
period we're in it repeats itself every
eighty years all the way back to the
beginning of time and it's a fascinating
study on who we are and where we are and
why voices like yours are rare
and what usually happens to people like
you only to retire early no I'm telling
you to stand strong but if it'll have a
happy ending the next generation oh you
grant see the heifer but I've got a
house I dunno I don't like what are you
doing um so where were we what were we
talking about again
where did we go there the road we're
gonna ride the government small
government oh man oh good luck
oh yeah so say so it's a rare moment
wank you see I don't do that one I don't
scared the hell out here
so two things happen first of all when I
heard the reporting on it I was like
this is horrible horrible yeah he meant
the Muslim ban I thought we weren't
supposed to take him literally yeah he
meant a Muslim man then I go and I read
the Muslim man it's a pause yeah okay so
where did the Muslim man come from well
partially him because as he's signing it
he's talking about banning Muslims what
the hell are you doing what are you
doing
I think he's either just so sloppy with
his language which is really easy to do
or he's sending a message to those
people that did vote for him was like
yeah I want you to ban all those Muslims
I don't know I don't know how big of a
number that is so he started calling it
a ban the press started calling it a ban
so there's there's two sides one he made
the mistake of saying that if you want
to be present in the United States you
have to be careful with your language I
was sitting in with George W Bush
because I really disagreed with the way
the war was being fought and he called
me into the Oval Office and read me the
riot act and he sat down we sat in those
two chairs by the fireplace you know and
he sat down and he said you know a lot
of people think they know what it's like
to be the president United States but
they have no an idea what it's like to
be the president of like this is going
to be the longest hour of my life okay
never heard him swear never saw him
angry huh he was pissed he said let me
tell you something and he started in on
private o'clock in the morning he took
phone calls he told me the names of the
people that had died where they died
what they were fighting for what their
parents said when he called them at 7:00
that morning and then he told me about
how the war was going and I said and he
was passionate
he wasn't the well a you know a shoe
yeah he wasn't that guy yeah
and I said no offense mr. president but
this is the guy that should be talking
to the American people where is all this
he said when you're president just
shifting your eyes is being watched by
the Chinese by your enemies by your
friends when you say something and if
you just shift your eyes there is
somebody in the world going what does
that mean yeah he said you have to watch
every single word you say Donald Trump
need to learn that lesson the same thing
needs to understood by the by the media
they're not intellectually honest
they're not intellectually curious very
few of them they also are sending a
message to the entire world America
hates Muslims now America has gone
insane America is not trustworthy
they're both at fault
they're both it fault so do we now have
the perfect storm we have a guy that
they've painted as Hitler versus a media
that we know will not act honesty there
are some actors within that that will
act honestly but we have a perfect storm
where no matter what he does they're
going to go nuts and no matter what they
do he's going to hate them so like we've
created now a situation where it gets to
what I first wanted to start with have
you ever seen a period of time in your
life where everyone seems like they're
going nuts at the same time because
that's what it seems like to me everyone
that I'm talking to and everyone's
saying it people are starting to say it
to each other feel like everyone's going
crazy oh yeah everyone's going crazy I
mean there really seems
to be like I think is what you're talk
about if it the 80 year thing that
there's like this sort of we're pulling
the string on the fabric of what so let
me give you one thing that might not
make you feel good and then something
that will make that feel good at one you
say about perfect storm a reoccurring
phrase on my show at Fox and the
chalkboard was perfect storm and it was
a president that would would happily
decree things through executive order a
press that was completely either in the
pocket or untrustworthy and a people
that were angry and one more element
economic collapse if you put economic
real economic depression like hardships
there yeah
look out it's cut it's going to fall
apart and it's going to get nasty ugly
now let me give you the part that'll
make you feel good I don't know why but
I have I feel a tremendous pull or
calling to stand for people who are
being persecuted one way or another and
and it it I don't know how that plays
out but it's why I have said it's why I
stood with Bill Maher two weeks after
9/11 he doesn't even know this here I'm
talk radio right after 9/11 not popular
to stand with the guy who says you know
what they're braver than our soldiers
not popular and he basically got fired
right and I said with him saying ABC
what part of what part of the name
politically incorrect don't you
understand
he has a right to say this so I tried to
stand with the people who are standing
on principle and even if I disagree with
them but this is
nested itself with me about five years
ago I took my children to Auschwitz and
I wanted my family to decide who we
would be before any trouble would come
and I said someday I hope not but
history seems to repeat itself and I
feel like we're headed towards this
where it's only heroes or villains and
depending on whose side wins they're
going to be villains and they could be
the Japanese they could be the the
Germans they could be the Jews they
could be us don't know but who are we
going to be at that time so we went
through
outch wits which was a an amazing
experience and then I found a woman who
was one of the Righteous among the
Nations she was one who saved about a
hundred Jews she was 16 at the time when
she did it and her story is phenomenal
but the last thing I asked her was my
kids and everybody had left and I said
to her I'm on television and radio and I
believe these times are coming again I
believe everybody has the seed of
righteousness in us but it has to be
watered so I asked her how can I water
that tree of righteousness how can i
water it in people to make it grow she
said something that I thought was
profound then but as we are entering
these times how you just described it
makes more sense than ever
she said Glenn you have to remember
you're looking at it from your time not
our time not the time when I was doing
it she said the righteous didn't
suddenly become righteous they were
superheroes
they just refused to go over the cliff
with everyone else so you don't we're in
that time where everybody's like oh my
gosh the world is going insane yes
they're going over the cliff of insanity
it's critical that you say stop I'm not
going there I won't go with you
no matter how much you push how much you
shoved no matter how much anger you want
to stir up in me I won't go over the
cliff with you you're going to end up
being one of the righteous remembered is
one of the righteous because you just
stood in place and everybody else went
nuts
[Music]
you